I don't like the taste of this although
I think it tastes like feet hi I'm
Rochelle
hi I'm destiny I'm Spencer I'm Jasmine
today we're gonna be testing out mac and
cheese and we're gonna try to guess
which one is vegan I actually love you
can food I love vegan alternatives and I
like restaurants that sort of like all
vegan everything I work in travelling
food so I kind of have grown to love
everything I'm working on it but vegan
food is actually really good you
wouldn't think so
I think vegan food is disgusting
straight straight up I don't like
substitutes of anything like like if
you're just gonna eat this type of foods
just eat it I've never had vegan mac and
cheese before yeah me either
I feel like I'll be able to tell the
difference yeah I don't think it'll be
two cars I did not know that this would
be blindfold did I still look good with
my outfit so I'm not that mad about it
oh oh it smells so good about my
utensils are right here okay where is it
is it on my fork yes thank you ma'am I
mean it's obviously pasta I don't know
if it's because it's vegan or because it
was frozen and is now reheated but
there's a creaminess factor that's
missing to me the sauce seems like
really thin and kind of white so I'm
like is this vegan maybe I feel like
this might be the vegan one because it
has a very heavy like umami mushroom
flavor that's overwhelming the whole
flavor palate of this dish why are you
laughing at me Spencer you're just so
specific there is a little bit of spice
in there which I think they're trying to
like compensate for the lack of real
cheese yes yes I agree I think this one
is vegan that's like
my verdict Sam can't really smell
anything
kind of nervous I'm really scared Oh is
it good it screaming I don't like the
taste of this although I think it tastes
like feet if it tastes like feet it's
probably feel cheese the cheese does
taste kind of like nacho II but I almost
like feel like I taste some dairy in
there and I'm lactose intolerant
severely so I would know oh this could
be an instant mac and cheese with like
the orange powder there's a little bit
of grittiness and then when you reduce
it it does get a little sticky and a
little thick I'm gonna go with vegan for
now what No yeah it may not be like the
freshest cheese but it's not vegan
are you ready put it down wow you guys
are fast and quiet okay are you ready I
know my mac and cheese not vegan I could
be completely wrong then they look like
an [ __ ] oh I feel like mine's really
yummy like mine's very cheesy
I don't know was the second Bowl vegan
is this the real cheese like I'm getting
all kind of mixed up now I think this is
real cheese tastes like cheese and it
feels like cheese yes it feels like
cheese feels like cheese this tastes
like fried chicken this is reminding me
of KFC it's reminding me of places that
serve mac and cheese so I think this is
probably not naked yeah I don't think
this was vegan either this reminds me of
what I lived off of in college this is
by far the cheesiest maybe slash the
creamiest one out of the bunch we've had
you know it pales in comparison to my
homemade mac and cheese but you know if
you have nothing else to eat in the
moment sure we've tried all three mac
and cheese dishes I think number one is
vegan okay
I'm gonna go out on a limb I'm gonna say
that option number two was vegan really
yeah
let's take up her black boy huh Oh God
just looking at them now I think I can
confirm I think number one is vegan
I still think number two is vegan look
at this
where's the cheese Wow vegan is number
one
[Applause]
lactose intolerance never laugh she's
the food person I'm not supposed to know
anything I just eat things I know can I
keep I gotta keep my job done right oh
I'm so sad I do not go with plate number
one because honestly I think I
second-guess myself one not shocked that
it's vegan two not shocked that it's
delicious I think that if I ordered this
at a restaurant I don't think I would
have been like oh this is mac and cheese
but it is a very good pasta dish yeah I
mean it was good I mean I did the only
one I didn't like was number two and
it's not vegan so yes I like mushrooms
yeah I would eat it even as someone with
severe lactose intolerance problems I
would still rather have full dairy mac
and cheese and ruin my entire day before
I had vegan mac and cheese
dang I'm definitely not eating vegan mac
and cheese I just feel like when we got
to option number three and I could taste
how like creamy and cheesy it was I was
just a whole I understand like if you
choose to have a vegan diet and you want
to eat something that is reminiscent of
mac and cheese why you would go for it I
think it's really awesome that if you're
a vegan you can still enjoy mac and
cheese too
[Music]